the PC is the best gaming platform you
can buy the end okay okay I guess
they're gonna make me elaborate a little
more though to me the reasons you should
own a PC for gaming are so obvious I
might as well just list a bunch of games
for the next five minutes but I'm not
allowed to do that either so here you go
the reasons you should buy a gaming PC
in 2014 a PC made from moderately
powerful hardware gives you access to
the most games the prettiest games and
the most interesting games from the past
the present and the future and before
you go off on the cost of building a PC
for games
remember that running most current games
doesn't mean spending an arm a leg and a
remaining pinky toe on powerful hardware
and fancy liquid cooling systems the
repertoire is seemingly endless loaded
with classics modern gems and fanciful
experiments that are changing the face
of the industry a simple look at steam
valves digital storefront tells you most
of what you need to know most of the
so-called triple-a games that monopolize
the conversation find a home on the PC
you know the ones Assassin's Creed Call
of Duty Bioshock and so forth and not
only do many of these games find their
way to the PC but they look visually
superior in almost all instances making
the PC the one system you need if good
looks are your primary concern but as
important as many of the multi-platform
games are PC exclusives like League of
Legends and Starcraft 2 dominate the
eSports scene while innovative games
like minecraft and dayz not only found
and built audiences on the PC but
introduced continuing trends that
inspire development studios on every
platform and if you want to take a trip
down memory lane or experience the
classics of their day for the first time
games like Planescape torment and Deus
Ex are easily available and every bit as
wonderful as they once were the advent
of the pre-release purchase and the rise
of crowdfunding have
shirred that the future of pc games is
as bright as the Blazing Sun Starbound
isn't even officially out yet over a
million people have already purchased it
and there's star citizen chris Roberts
upcoming space sim which has raised an
astounding amount of money from
crowdfunding but lest you think the PC
is all about independent development
we've got games on the horizon like
Dragon Age Inquisition and The Witcher 3
and I haven't even mentioned cool
hardware like the oculus rift which
makes Kinect look like child's play PC
are the machines for everyone that do
everything if you like playing games
you'll find almost every kind of
experience here from farmville to FIFA
from God games to gone home the PC is
the gaming platform that truly has it
all